look at his muscles he's not missed leg
day
kissing very unhappy in your husband
[Music]
that's an angry wombat piece
he's he's not happy oh jesus
piss off it's got quite a mouse on him
the bloke i mean not the wombat
piss off your bastard it's really rare
for them to do this like this has to be
a pretty
aggravated little individual normally
when a wombat feels threatened it will
run away and go into its burrow when
wombats attack eh
jesus christ but they can be
aggressive and they do have strong
little legs and they are
heavy and their primary weapon is the
charge
oh you bastard piss off it's
pretty amazing and this guy's getting it
in full they just
run at you and uh there's a little bit
of biting around the ankles that can
happen
i didn't realize wombats had such big
teeth eh
hey oh he's got a scratch yeah wombat
teeth
are pretty cool which is a phrase i know
you never thought that you would look at
on social media
they actually keep on growing the whole
entire life
of the wombat and that's because they
use it to grind so much vegetation
they just keep on growing and wearing
them down over their whole life
the best thing to do would probably be
to beat a retreat and let the wombat you
know
calm down
okay we've got our next one
[Music]
kissing oh dear this very unhappy
emu you can see that that bird when it's
aggressive it's standing up very tall
making itself big by sort of fluffing up
its
fluffy feathers all over its neck and
you heard really beautiful sound in this
one
both hissing which is extremely sort of
aggressive
and the bombing which is the emu's
native sound and it
does it by inflating an air sac and
whomping it
is one being a technical term no
womp
[Music]
why are you upsetting that emu mate put
the camera down and get out of there
there is no doubt an emu could hurt you
with those huge claws
they're three-toed and their middle toe
is
much much bigger perfect for
disembowelling you
i mean i haven't heard of it happening
all right we've got two kangaroos and
we're
in someone's front yard geez they're big
hey
i'm really good hey bro oh
skippy would be absolutely slaughtered
in this
scenario i think that these will both be
males it's
normal that males will be fighting and
generally
not females they're trying to sort out a
bit of a hierarchy he'll stand as
tall as a person especially when they're
upright and being aggressive like this
the head tilt yeah yeah the grapple
without looking
that's because they're actually trying
to get their head away from being
scratched or you know your brain is
really important to your functioning so
you want to do everything you can to
protect it in a fight
and they will sit back onto that big
tail and actually
do a kangaroo kick like a boof and that
can
disembowel an opponent if the angle is
right
so they also have really strong thick
skin on their tummies to protect against
other kangaroos i wouldn't get that
close
how many rounds are in this it's like
mortal kombat
it's really unusual to see extended
kangaroo fights
they normally sorted out pretty quickly
so these two guys look pretty evenly
matched
imagine how much energy this sort of
thing would take they're going to be
tired injured hungry
after they do this and then they've got
to go out and bonk a lady so it's
hard
[Music]
okay why has he got it on his hand
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we've all been there well actually we
don't all have friends like that
i hope the spider's all right so even
though they're not
harmful to humans they're still going to
give you a fright these guys will only
bite when
they've been absolutely really hassled
into it and they have pretty big fangs
so they can pierce human skin
but they have fairly weak venom so
it means that you might get a reaction
and swelling but really
it's not going to hurt you beyond that
daniel on a donkey just keep pressure
keep pressure
it's all right clearly there must be a
crocodile there somewhere i cannot see
it yes daniel
quick bro the big
[Laughter]
they're quite close to the edge of the
water there guys
run back bro run back bro run back bro
run back all right run run run run run
run daniel run run daniel oh that is
he wants the fishy give him the fish oh
no he's got it
pressure on keep the pressure oh look
how proud of himself he looks no
it's so big it's so big he's swallowing
it
to be fair i don't think that that
crocodile was going for the humans it
was going for
the fish the stats indicate that there
are maybe
two attacks a year less fatalities not
that many fatalities a year from
crocodile attack
but there's things that you can do to
avoid this situation
if you're camping make sure you camp at
least 50 meters away from the edge of
the water
and if you're going down to get water in
a bucket or otherwise make sure that you
go to a different spot
on the river every time so that you're
not habituating
that crocodile to know where you're
going to be
[Music]
hoped you like that one and if you did
hit subscribe for more videos
and if you've got a suggestion for an
animal that you'd like me to
look at for how deadly why don't you
leave your suggestions in the comments
below
and i'll make sure i read them i'll
catch you next time